it is the nice blood of this world
we're hard brittle
you scum good
ladies and gentlemen please welcome
Chris waters
ladies and gentlemen of the Horde and
the Alliance alike welcome to warlords
of Draenor worldwide cinematic premiere
I want to thank all of you here in that
ace theater in downtown Los Angeles for
coming out today and all of you for
tuning in and watching online my name is
Chris waters I can usually be found
talking about games playing games
generally celebrating how awesome games
are on gamespot com but today I'm here
we're all here to celebrate one awesome
game World of Warcraft has touched
millions of people all around the world
and y'all were not the only people
lining up for an event like this today
in China in Korea and that blizzards
booth in cologne germany at Gamescom
hundreds and thousands of you have all
come out to see what Blizzard has to
offer and it's going to be a great show
in addition to the warlords of Draenor
intro cinematic we've also got a brand
new animated series that delves deep
into the lure of World of Warcraft's
we're going to talk with world of
warcraft developers about all the new
features you can expect once worlds of
dren warlords of Draenor goes live and
of course Blizzard legends Mike Moore
hime and Chris Metzen are here it's
gonna be a great show so let's kick it
off in earnest please join me in giving
a warm welcome to Blizzard CEO and
co-founder Mike Moore hi
everyone I want to thank you all for
coming I want to thank everyone on the
stream for tuning in guys are a great
crowd as as many of you know this air
marks the 20th anniversary of the
original Warcraft orcs and humans
strategy game and the 10th anniversary
of World of Warcraft we've all made some
awesome memories together created close
friendships and shared some great times
playing these games over the years and
that is a big reason why we're really
excited about warlords of Draenor this
expansion takes world of warcraft back
to the roots of Warcraft you'll explore
the orc homeworld and establish your own
base of operations as you fight for the
future of Azeroth two of the designers
on the game in huzzah costas and brian
whole inca are here and they'll talk
more about what you can expect from the
expansion we also have Chris Metzen here
to debut some really cool stuff for you
Chris will get into the legendary
characters and events that form the
foundation of this fantasy world that we
are all part of that's all coming up
along with the date when the next
chapter of World of Warcraft will go
live
and without further ado I'd like to turn
the show back over to our host Chris
waters all right we're gonna get set up
for an interview just a second here but
first I want to hear from you folks in
the crowd how many of you are here
standing strong representing the
Alliance
well I guess that also answers my next
question how many of you here are
running with the whole
sounds like you got your work cut out
for you alliance alright please join me
in welcoming to the stage world of
warcraft developers ian has it cost us
and Brian ha lenka
how about this crowd guys pretty [ __ ]
up this is incredible this is like a
little mini blizzcon on the middle Los
Angeles on a Thursday morning how about
that you see this woman over here she's
got full face paint fangs also I'll get
up all right this guy here at tuesday at
1pm so yeah all right gents let's get
into it here but first give the folks a
little bit of touch point for what you
do at blizzard what your work on world
of warcraft consists of sure yeah my
name is brian olenka and i'm a senior
game designer on world of warcraft and
specifically i spend most of my time
working on pvp i think some people here
like they fear a few yeah my name is ian
has a hostess i'm one of the lead game
designers on Wow watch her on the forums
and on Twitter and yeah I do a bunch of
different things work with the dungeon
and raid team that makes the encounters
for the game and a little bit of systems
and class stuff here and there but DX
super excited to be here right on fellas
well every time there's an expansion for
world of warcraft it's a chance for
people of all levels to dive back into
chase new loot to chase new levels but i
don't know and if this resonates with
any of you out there but it can be a
little daunting for some of those of us
who are more modestly leveled shall we
say but in warlords of draenor you guys
have introduced a level 90 boost its
gonna sort of address that and help
folks out can you talk to us a little
bit about it yeah sure we're definitely
aware that there are a lot of folks in
that boat maybe not the people sitting
right here so I know you guys are all
hardcore level 90s but maybe you want to
switch maybe you want to switch
characters maybe you want to switch
means coming into the expansion so we
want to make sure that when you when you
get were little drown or when you log in
to face this new adventure you can
really jump right in to drown or you
don't necessarily want to find yourself
at level 73 in grizzly hills and oh wow
you've got a lot of ground to cover
before you can get there so no matter
what when you have were loaded run or
you'll be able to boost one of your
characters to level 90 whether it's a
brand new character or an existing one
and you will find yourself facing the
dark portal with this new adventure
lying ahead of you and as you go through
and have your initial assault on the
dark portal
we have a structured experience kind a
little bit like the old death knight
starting experience where we will pare
down your bars make sure you only have a
few buttons initially so you're not
necessarily overwhelmed by a new spec or
if you're coming back to the game after
many years you know changes that have
happened while you were away then as you
go through the adventure as you progress
on your initial mission things will
unfold things will unlock you get new
abilities you get new talents and next
thing you know it you're ready to take
on train our excellent so easy folks in
for when they want to jump into the deep
end pretty much and so when when I've
you know I've rolled my new deny paladin
I'm rolling out their level 90 boosted
what is was my character looking like
what kind of stuff am i bringing along
so yeah that's that's one of the really
exciting things about this expansion we
finally taken the time to go back and
updates all of our character models from
vanilla as well as you know the drown
eyes since they're such a prominent race
that you're going to find in drown or
will be getting to the other ones in the
very very near future but yeah so all
new all new high def looks the same time
you also might notice that you know
we've cleaned up people's bars a little
bit we recognize that over you know many
many years we kind of added and layered
on abilities that were often a little
bit redundant or maybe not strictly
necessary and we really wanted to kind
of streamline get back to the basics the
core of what each class is also give us
some more room to add cool things in the
future because at some point like once
you have all your key vines all your
action bar stays full there's no where
to go from there so really gearing up
for a fresh start and sort of a new
chapter in the world of warcraft exactly
alright well speaking of warcraft i
mentioned before that I worked for
gamespot and about 20 years ago a little
less i was visiting gamespot and
downloading a free demo for warcraft too
and i think i played that so much got so
wrapped up in that RTS awesomeness i
still have the sucks ugh ends in your
name like lodged back in my lizard brain
uh so imagine my delight when you guys
are kind of bringing that RTS game play
back into warlords of Draenor yeah you
get a little bit of that from the
garrison it's definitely putting the
Warcraft back in World of Warcraft um
you know your mission on Draenor is to
take on to take down the iron horde and
it's mighty heroes mighty a champion as
you may be you know having felled the
lich king deathwing all these great
enemies
even you can't handle that on your own
you need an army at your back and that
is your initial mission really to
establish a base an outpost and raise
the army that will help you take down
the iron horde and in so doing really
you're claiming a plot of land building
it up making a number of choices along
the way whether you know whether you
want a lumber mill or a stables whether
you want an armory or a mage tower and
those choices are going to shape your
adventure through drown or and really
give you a way to kind of customize
level up and have this struck me a
feeling of hey this is my base and i own
a part of it because we all want ways to
feel more powerful don't we building up
that garrison is that sound good to you
guys all right well I want to talk to
you a little bit now Brian because while
building up my garrison and marshaling
my friends to go on and take on the the
AI nefarious demons that await us may be
very satisfying sometimes you just want
to suit up and go head-to-head with
another player yeah in Ashe ran the new
pvp realm that's what we're going to be
doing absolutely you know warlords of
Draenor is a very exciting time for
anyone that likes PvP in the world of
warcraft bring a lot of changes on new
features things like skirmishes back
into the fold there's really more to do
as a PvP player and World of Warcraft
than ever before and a big part of that
is astron when we are thinking about
features for warlords of Draenor there
were PvP oriented we were like you know
we didn't want to do we have arenas and
we love arenas and they're really cool
for going in there and pitting your met
you know your abilities against someone
else with battlegrounds where players
can feel a part of the Alliance or the
Horde and battle for you know Rafi basin
or song called and that structured stuff
is really fun but we wanted to kind of
bring a new type of PvP content
something that feels like world pvp you
know in the world of warcraft so we
wanted to set out and make a pvp
playground place that you know if i
don't want to do arenas i don't want to
do battle grounds but I want to just
kind of go out and beat some heads
there's a place for me to do it and
that's what Iran is this island is off
the east coast of turn on its kind of
isolated there if it's an old ogre city
and civilization that's kind of fallen
into ruin the Alliance and horde is
treated they're following the raid on
the Dark Portal they're kind of
regathering their strength their so
horror bases on the north side the
Alliance space is on the south side and
what do you know you put the Alliance
and the Horde on an island and it
doesn't go so well like I'm sure right
so there's this massive tug-of-war going
on you know between the Horde and the
lights kind of pushing between the two
bases it's one of the most epic huge
fights you've ever seen our beta people
have just been flocking to it huge
fights really awesome stuff kind of
harkens back to the days when all trac
Valley used to go on for four or five
days used to spawn those epic units all
that kind of stuff is kind of coming
back and you know if you don't
necessarily want to jump into that your
gameplay around the outside of the
island we have these four different
little areas they're kind of themed in
different ways they've got different
creatures there that you can kill and
slay you can earn things called artifact
fragments which are kind of a strands
currency you can use that currency to go
by different things for your team for
yourself and it kind of provides the
opportunity for that roaming five-man
PvP group to got to come back into the
fold so it's really cool and something
brand-new that you've never really
experienced before but you know anytime
we do something like that we don't want
to you know a lot of our realms are kind
of like mostly horde or mostly Alliance
so we're using some of our new
technology to say oh you know
tichondrius is mostly horde okay we'll
grab them and will pit them against
another server that's mostly Alliance so
they'll be coming together in a strand
so for the most part the populations be
well-balanced it'll be a good experience
for everybody sounds pretty good to me
now when you're Brian talking about sort
of stuff you can sort of go off the
beaten path and earn different purchase
new things unlock different abilities
you said the word playground earlier you
guys are getting a little bit playful in
the kinds of abilities you're allowing
players to flex in ashran we just
unleashed our designers two guys Chris
kaliki Morgan they are just been unlike
just being super creative with
everything that's in there because one
thing about world PvP is kind of finding
other ways to have an advantage you know
whether you're you know sneaking up on
somebody or you've just found that item
that is the awesome item that's really
one of the the classic parts about world
pvp and so what players can do is one of
the cool things that they could find on
some of the monsters out there are these
special tones their particular for your
class and they give your class kind of a
limited time buff that's a little crazy
like you don't want these in arena
believe me you know they're things like
priests they're levitate spell kind of
lets them fly off the ground for a while
and cast spells and heal and powtoons
can lay down judgment on their enemies
and send them to the faction prison
where the nevada on beta we had these
guys are peeing they were called the the
jailers of ash ran and they just hung
out in those jails and every time
somebody would show up they would
inflict punishment on them lay down
judgment so very cool very cool stuff
and you know for all that punishment
that you're inflicting for you know all
those great sort of power moves your
polling there's there's glory in victory
there's honor but I is there some some
extra loot you can maybe gain from the
process as well well you know F has that
opportunity for us to really rewrite the
rules and so one of the things we're
doing different is that artifact
fragments that currency naturally I was
talking about before you kill another
player you can loot half their a shrine
fragments so you're basically looting
player
so so it brings a whole new dynamic to
world pvp in warlords of Draenor Brian
it sounds like you got a lot of excited
people just before anything around yeah
guys want off lewd each other pvp of
course always been a part of the beating
heart of World of Warcraft as has lore
and with warlords of Draenor gives you
guys a chance to explore sort of new
realms and new parts of lore but one of
the things that's coming back around in
a big way is that old Dark Portal you
guys we've seen the Dark Portal for
years now sorry the Dark Portal we agree
not you have to say that you have to say
that way yeah Smart's my bad folks uh en
can you tell us more about the role of
the Dark Portal in warlords of Draenor
yeah it's kind of a big deal I mean
really going all the way back to you
know the Warcraft 2 expansion it was
called beyond the Dark Portal for a
reason the Dark Portal is the first
thing you're going to see when you log
into orla to drown or it's both the
first threat that is posed to you and
post to Azeroth as a whole and your
first objective even though you know
this is happening in Indiana or distant
world there's a very immediate
existential threat which is that the
iron horde led by Grommash is going to
march their forces and their weaponized
armored grahn and their siege machinery
right through the dark portal and just
lay waste to the entirety of Azeroth
stormwind orgrimmar all of it and it's
up to us to stop them yikes exactly not
so that so the very first thing that you
do is going to be embarking through the
Dark Portal on something of a suicide
mission to sabotage it and shut it down
spoilers you don't actually die eat but
and then from there you're in winning
the initial battle but certainly far
from winning the war you've bought
yourself some breathing room a little
bit of time by shutting down that
eminent invasion but you still need to
raise that army to work on Draenor to
defeat the iron horde and stop that
threat from actually being realized and
now this invasion I mean that sounds a
lot like one of these world events that
you guys are fond of kicking off your
expansions with am I right folks
can you tell us a little bit about sort
of how your presaging warlords of
draenor sort of being released into the
wild a little bit of that yeah I mean we
don't some fun stuff in the past you
know like the zombie plague things along
those lines it's always nice to throw a
little twist see so what we're going to
be doing in the 6-point opatch before
drown or itself on locks is having
basely showing you this initial Vanguard
this initial iron horde threat they have
this first incursion through the Dark
Portal that's basically laid waste to
blasted lands nether guard keep is now
in ruins the Alliance and horde are
scrambling to understand this new threat
to understand what's happened and to
kind of rally their forces in response
and you were part of that first group
that's sent to investigate to learn
what's happened there at the same time
what's also going on is that an initial
part of this force has made its way to
upper Blackrock Spire to rendezvous with
a certain warlords ayla with whom you
have some unfinished business from siege
of orgrimmar perhaps and that's going to
be a max level dungeon in warlords of
Draenor however as part of the
pre-release event we're going to have a
special level 90 preview version of that
available for a limited time only where
you can go into level 90 new upper
Blackrock Spire and fight your way
through the first half of the dungeon
get some relevant Luke to prepare
yourself for an hour and get a taste of
things to come sound good
and I think you've probably sold them
all here already but like let's talk a
little bit about Draenor as a world this
isn't the first new world that has been
introduced to world of warcraft but with
each new expansion with each new world
you bring you you gotta carve out a new
niche for you got to distinguish it and
give folks something new gate tell us a
little bit about what sets Draenor apart
from the other worlds they've explored
yeah I mean for us it was really a
chance to go back and explore what this
world would have been like had you know
what ruined it and turned it into
outland not occurred it's the birthplace
of the orcs it's the home of the dhryn I
it's a chance to explore these
civilizations these societies that their
height and while there's some familiar
kind of nostalgic callbacks to players
who played the burning crusade it's
ultimately a brand new world built from
scratch from the ground up you know
there is a zone called shadow moon
valley but it's not the shadow moon
valley you might remember from outland
where there's fell fire raining from the
sky and Illidan standing atop his black
temple telling you how unprepared you
are this time around it's you know
rolling green hills with eternal
Twilight skies as Shadow and cultists
conduct dark rich rules under Stonehenge
like monuments like totally totally
different vibe and that's just you know
a taste of what the world has to offer
we're really excited to have you know
realized this our artists our
environment team did an incredible job
putting this world together we can't
wait to share it with you all give you
guys wait to get into that
alright ian has it cost us Brian
hanukkah thank you gentlemen so much for
hyping us up about warlords of Draenor
getting into some of the nitty-gritty of
what it's all about let's hear it for
him folks now all that stuff Ian and
Brian were just talking about you're
gonna get a glimpse of it a little bit
later in the show you're gonna get a
look at garrisons what they look like
how you can customize them you're gonna
get a look at shadow moon valley looking
positively peaceful as ian was saying
you check out all the new environments
of warlords of Draenor that's coming up
in a little bit but first remember I
mentioned a new animated series deep
delving into the lure of World of
Warcraft it's time to see that in action
but I'm not the guy to introduce that to
you that guy is a blizzard senior vice
president of story and franchise
development please welcome to the stage
Chris Metzen
what out
thanks guys good morning Los Angeles
how's everybody doing excellent
excellent guys thank you for being here
with us this morning uh I want to get
some to hoard where you at Alliance let
me hear you
proud defenders of Azeroth guys we got
some cool stuff in store for you this
morning you know it's not every day we
get to debut one of these cinematic
intros it's it's actually I think today
is the first time we've ever done a
community event to roll out one of our
cinematics these cinematics are near and
dear to our hearts especially the intro
is obviously not only do they kind of
set up the the framework of the story
the characters the conflict you know the
the vector of the adventure to come but
we also just personally we love these
cinematics because they're kind of the
spear tip of imagination right they get
the whole experience moving and I think
I hope that they show that the tender
love and care the passion and
craftsmanship that we try to put into
our product so i will get to it in just
a moment i hope you guys love it like we
do but before we get to it we brought
something a little additional today to
set it up i want to ask you guys a
question how many of you last year saw
the burdens of shaohao excellent so over
the years we've built the products we we
kind of construct the story that flows
to the expansion sets our story
developers usually want to run a little
deeper or get into characters
backstories kind of bridge the products
together we love telling stories and
often we've done that over the years
through novels comics manga graphic
novels things like that and we love that
stuff but with show how we kind of took
this new vector and we created kind of
this serial sequence of animation kind
of this rough illustrative style like an
animated storybook and we loved it we
love making it it seemed like people
liked it a lot and the fact that it's
kind of just these little free pieces of
animation to watch it went out far and
wide right I just you know I don't know
youtube or wherever else it cast a very
wide net we had a lot of people have a
lot of fun with that product so based on
Xiao how we looked at warlords of
Draenor we thought well what can we do
what kind of animation can we produce
whoa and kind of be able to take people
back to this era of Draenor and express
and explain some of the back stories of
certain of these warlords kind of get in
their heads kind of you know illustrate
what makes them tick what are they
motivated by why are they such rotten
bastards that we need to bring to
justice so very happy to show you guys
this morning actually the first episode
of Lords of war this episode features
one of our warlords ado de name of car
gasps blade fist it's kind of funny it
strikes me that car gas in a number of
his buddies were created as characters
oh my god almost 20 years ago I don't
know how that's possible but what that
means is most world of warcraft players
had never met these guys have never done
quest with them or fought with them or
you know kind of you know taking them
down as raid bosses so this series right
in its heart really wants to you know
take you inside these characters and
show you why you should care why you
want to face them and bring them to
justice as we said before so guys
without further ado very pleased to
present chapter one of Lords of war
king ferry the hour grows late you must
sign the declaration of war I was just a
child when my father rushed to confront
this same evil he didn't understand this
warlords at all that mistake cost him
his life and brought this kingdom to
ruin you are not your father I know but
how can I succeed where he failed you
can start by thrust in my counsel I have
faced them before under an Arn you were
there all those years ago yes believe me
they are not invincible then tell me of
them Iran tell me everything very well
karva gas had no play
he was raised a slave ogres cruelty was
in top
so he sought a way out the arena
100 applies was the price for freedom
fight kill salute
car gas was unstoppable and the day of
his final fight had come one last Kim
and it was over
100 lives kharghar can earn his reward
like every champion before him
bill Heath beneath the arena the promise
of freedom nothing but a lie but kargad
would be chained to no longer
take your vengeance
bound by finches their name would be
spoken in fear this was the birth of the
shattered hand
oh well hope you guys enjoyed that as
you can see the age of the whimsical
panda sadly is over the Warcraft of old
is back and it is as savage as ever we
have four more episodes of Lords of war
they're going to be debuting over the
next number of weeks we are not
featuring every warlord in the series
I'm just very pivotal ones that really
affect the way the story is going to
play out in the game but we wanted to
give you guys a sneak peek at some of
the visuals of the rest of the series
you can kind of get a sense of kind of
where it goes and how epic it feels so
without further ado take a look at the
teaser for the rest of this series of
Lords of war
you guys looking forward to more Lords
of war learn more about this rogues
gallery back here yes please alright so
I mentioned before after the interview
that you're going to get a look at dren
or inaction a look at all the new areas
a look at garrisons a look at the pvp
madness of ashran that happens now enjoy
you
you
well guys the time has come see the
cinematic you've come here to see a
super excited you know guys in in so
many ways Warcraft is so much more in
the game you know we set out 20 years
ago to build you know Warcraft orcs and
humans and it's been this crazy I know
sometimes it feels like a runaway train
ever since 20 years of developing an
idea and how amazing to see some of
these old ideas come around again and
feel new but Warcraft is so much more
than a game it really is the community
where's Tibbs out of noon dude this
guy's first in line rapping last night
just crazy commitment like all of you
your commitment to be here and kind of
celebrate this moment with us is really
what it's all about I really can't
express to you how inspiring it is to be
here for events like this things like
blizzcon and should be able to hear you
to hear the passion really just stokes
us up and fuels our tanks and i can only
tell you we're working hard for you
we're listening we're giving this thing
everything we got so thanks again for
being here and just being part of this
community thanks guys
so warlords of draenor was a weird story
right I remember when we announced it at
blizzcon in that big room and you got
people going who got some people going
here right time travel Star Trek all
that weird stuff all the worries all the
way where you guys taken us you're in
good hands it strikes me though that the
fundamental idea that really sets up the
fiction of warlords of draenor tracks
itself all the way back something like
30 odd years in the past of Juran or a
specific moment in history where the
orcs came together and they struck a
deal a deal signed and corrupted blood a
deal that would shape the destinies of
two worlds and in a way history is
coming round again perhaps you'll see it
ain't going to go the way it went before
so while that sounds cryptic you're
about to get your first glance at the
beginning of warlords of Draenor
drink hellscream claim your destiny you
will all be conquerors there what Oh Dan
must we give in return everything
reject this gift
I did you bring these modules here just
to watch you die
this was not our destiny times change
we will never be slaves
but we will need conquerors
you
all through that
I don't know how Blizzard does it every
time but they do it every time that was
incredible all right ladies and
gentlemen you heard it here first
warlords of draenor launching on
November 13 2014 that's just a few days
after blizzcon any of y'all going to
blizzcon I had a feeling but you don't
have to wait until blizzcon to get more
awesome Blizzard stuff right now in
Germany at Gamescom the biggest european
gaming convention Blizzard Entertainment
is there running a lot of school stuff
out of their booth they've gotten news
they've got interviews they've got
contests and more so head on over to
Blizzard calm / gamescom to get all that
stuff about warlords of Draenor heroes
of the storm hearthstone and diablo 3
it's been quite a show hasn't it folks
thank you all for coming out again on
behalf of my colleagues at gamespot and
the incredible team here at blizzard
thanks for coming and have a great day